[Music]
and no sympathy for the poor news o
whatsoever that's submitted by a mango
sticky rice oh my god that's Bom
I'm a seasoned right now you can get it
it's good
some places several ice cream - that's
one of the only good agent desserts
market if I say it a lot - you know
these things yeah they're not that good
I've ever had shave ice it look I like
the concentrated [ __ ] explosions of
sugar and [ __ ] they're gonna shave ice
it's really good you have had shaved ice
of course the Koreans dominated it's
just a Mayan style though the Korean one
has a lot of flavors in it I just know a
lot of the desserts are like green tea
and on my pass pass every time those
ones are softer everything's [ __ ]
green tea or sponge cake that tastes
like nothing
a study suggests that TV shows which
glamorize Fame and luxury make viewers
cold-hearted towards the poor Dan I like
lifestyles of the rich and famous so a
study that says that TV shows which
glamorized Fame and luxury they say that
makes viewers cold-hearted towards the
poor people lifestyles of the rich and
famous I'm surprised you remember that
okay so happy today I love that [ __ ] all
it's not what the same announcer and all
that stuff but yeah that guy was great
though his lifestyle his lifestyles of
the rich and famous members starts he's
living the sweet boy
it's the British dude yeah never mind
he's on MTV is it that one I think he
was a vh1 show where they show you dope
ass houses I love that [ __ ] we love crib
skirt I like them too because those are
dope oh [ __ ] they always made the same
joke this is where the magic happens
gonna get on their own bed every time
downside it on slow motion that was
you're the best MTV Cribs one was
[ __ ] red man how's that he still
lives in you know this right here
supposed to be a switch but it's just an
electrical wire did he make grilled
cheese sandwich with an iron it was like
it was like the funniest one because
he's still living the same spot I
remember Shaq's that was a good one his
bed was [ __ ] that was huge and you
could already tell his wife hated him
yeah it was a great episode his wife at
the time was that really short girl
right yeah well sort o yeah just
probably like my height yeah I thought
the giraffe next to him was short too
and his petting zoo like holy [ __ ] dude
that guy's huge bucket dress that was
trash [ __ ] Realty not--there's knowing
your lifestyle there balling up
Calabasas life yeah they talk about
$3,000 purses all the time the ones that
don't do that are the [ __ ] Mexican
novellas though because you always feel
so bad for the the poor girl which is
always a poor girl and her family so
humble and so nice and then the rich
dude is always trying to hook up with
her own if it's not that well sometimes
they do have novellas where the poor
girl is a [ __ ] trying like good she's
like a super gold digger yeah tries to
get in with the rich family and then the
rich dude is just like some poor
innocent do it just fell in love with
her and then later on it turns out that
she's an evil [ __ ] it's complicated
storylines I know both sound like a
reality though I love it I love watching
rich people do [ __ ] I don't care I love
it well another one of their examples is
X Factor The Apprentice and so with this
this study here that they had they found
that even just 60 seconds of exposure to
material
mystic media was enough to significantly
increase anti-welfare sentiment that
think means that they just can't
empathize with the poor anymore after
just 60 seconds
well you can't glamorize the pork
lifestyles of the pardon unknown bucks
he made with toothpicks yeah it's like
here's a life anyone could have it's
like no things I want to see you like I
can't [ __ ] have it's more like like
you're not willing to help the poor
anymore after you're exposed to this
luxury because then people were thinking
about how can I save more money so I
could buy that yacht as soon as they
watch that that of like let me help my
fellow human I gotta work harder so I
could save more money and buy a [ __ ]
slide on my house which I can help the
neighborhood kids get into if they want
as soon as they see that they go oh [ __ ]
I got to save more money I'm blowing too
much so I gotta like I'm not gonna give
it to any of you because I don't think
that's to be viewed in a bad way like if
this guy sees like this sorry yeah if
they see like all these expensive things
like oh you know what I want to get that
too and if it's this person's own money
he has every right or a choice to spend
the money he wants to spend it so if
he's not gonna spend it on the poor
because his own choice I don't know why
do we all think gold toilets are [ __ ]
cool but they didn't have to spend money
on a gold toilet they could have given
the whatever amount of money to charity
and then get out in a regular toilet and
to us that's boring this [ __ ] yes of
course that could have happened but it's
so boring I could have took my [ __ ]
kidneys on and give it to someone that
needs it too but I want to keep both in
mind how about I want a gold toilet and
I can donate to poor people like
eventually when I after I get my second
or third a little toilet is the study
saying that people are being mean to
poor people not mean so let me break it
down it's exactly the way they're saying
it here then so you guys can understand
a little bit better so they're saying
for the research 487 adults were shown
for advertisements for luxury products
for tabloid photos of famous celebrities
showing our province of Goa and for
newspaper headlines of rags to riches
story a control group was exposed to
images like a bunny rabbit in carry
natural scenery [ __ ] trees I'm London
Underground news [ __ ] subway
dinosaurs dinosaurs both groups were
asked questions that measured their
attitudes towards wealth and success
government benefits and impoverished
people and then the results showed that
even a small amount of exposure to
materialistic media had a negative
impact on both anti-welfare attitudes
and support for anti Wolfer policy you
know what's funny though that they need
to do a study on materialism and luxury
things and how it could affect the mind
to me it's pretty common sense yeah
materialism is [ __ ] toxic and is
known in like in advertising circles so
no it's like what you learned first day
it's just funny that they have to that's
how [ __ ] up the world is is like we
have to do these studies to kind of like
say see I told you [ __ ] worshipping
that gold [ __ ] toilet is gonna [ __ ]
your head up but this is like telling
people the magic trick nobody cares you
still want to watch them at exactly you
can't stop human nature like if you're
middle class to poor you're just gonna
envy big yachts things that you can't
have wow they live like that it's
[ __ ] crazy
and everyone has that version of it you
know like some people like they might
not need they might not want the
expensive thing but some people they
might really want like travel or some
people might really want experience or
some people that are extremely busy they
go oh look at this guy here's a ton of
free time I want to have free time like
everyone has that luxury relative to
them that they don't have that they
still want yeah that's true though
because like my form of like what I want
out of life is to do nothing
mm-hmm like that's like what I want
every night one you want time
time happiness's be able to every [ __ ]
you want right yeah so like literally if
I could just wake up every day and do
whatever the [ __ ] I want which is kind
of like holidays right now but you know
but actually have money would be great
either you're tired cuz not right as of
right now the money thing is not there
so if you had that ad money that's
pretty good so it's like you get to
choose what your life goal is at the
moment like I'm gonna go buy another
Honda Element yep and I'm excited about
it and this Honda Element actually you
might have AC in it there you go and
then my tires have a had a nail in it so
yeah all the time for that yep yep like
90 degrees every day and I drove it
today well you saw the Tesla because I
forgot to charge it oh I definitely have
my [ __ ] portable sauna I drove it to
k-town yesterday at a conference call so
I had to roll up the windows all I can
think of is like what's right
it's [ __ ] cardio so bad or you need
to charge another car yeah but I did oh
you know why this is really interesting
to me is because not the way general
public views materialism is everybody is
a status chaser or they're buying it for
a certain reason but I know the the
seller side of the psychology is there's
different people that buy it for
different reasons majority might be like
it's a it's a humans want to want to
show what status they are like they'll
buy a Gucci thing because it's like I'm
better than you right that might be the
majority case but there are people who
are into this niche because they like
they're a hobbyist or you know like
they're there or they're there they're
really in like they're obsessed with
this certain designer or whatever and
there's so many different people that
are attracted to this stuff but not for
the same reasons
that's stereotypical like what it what
it does is it ends up causing social
irresponsibility I think that's what
this article is saying is like you're so
self-centered and thinking about things
that you want to buy that you're not
caring
about [ __ ] people starving while you
want to buy a nice watch I don't
empathize with the research only because
no [ __ ] you know I mean like it's yes
exactly
yeah yeah and also like okay so who are
these researchers do they drive Acuras
like do you know I'm saying like the
drive infinities they do I bet you they
have dope houses too
I bet you like they've had Gucci bags or
whatever level of dope this is accurate
I think that's not no policy or
infinities or infinity I get your point
though it's relative to materialism is
relative to your status yes so you might
look at Alexis and say you [ __ ]
ballin out you you you you know you're
just so like materialistic but there
might be a super rich person that goes
BMW Lexus that's cheap yep you know yeah
you know like my general thumb it's like
what I say is like if you could still do
it while nobody's watching that you
probably really like it true dude why
does anyone buy a Gucci bag because
you're you buy it so that because other
people can and you can you get a status
symbol that's the whole luxury yeah yeah
it's like I'm in the club you're not in
the club yeah cuz if everyone had a
Gucci bag wouldn't be cool to have a
Gucci bag it's like you can't afford it
look you it's it's inherent and all the
things you do and buy yep [ __ ] you
you're not part of my club and they ask
you if you want to cook winner in this
store thank you for that yeah so true I
wouldn't know I have never walked in
really
[Music]
[Music]